I am glad that I was introduced without  an economist joke wasn't so long ago  that I was introduced by the guy who  said Larry do you know what it takes to  succeed as an economist and I said no  and he said an economist is someone  who's pretty good with figures that  doesn't quite have the personality to be  an account it is instead occasionally  that I can be arrogant all the  introductions I've ever received  that was surely the most recent that  question was both predictable and a good  try the looks of it they wouldn't send  me books for the franchise one of the  things you learn as a college president  is that if an undergraduate is wearing a  tie and jacket there are two  possibilities one is that they're  looking for a job and have an interview  the other is that they are in you know  hard enough now focusing on longer  depart the problem he's the toxic mess  there are moments that are more pleasant  in moments that are better less pleasant